>> WELCOME TO CNN TONIGHT.
I'M JAKE TAPPER IN WASHINGTON.
AND TONIGHT MAKE AMERICA GREAT
AGAIN --
AGAIN?
WE ARE JUST FOUR DAYS AWAY FROM
THE ALL MIDTERM ELECTIONS AND
WITH REPUBLICANS OPTIMISTIC
THEY ARE GOING TO BE ABLE TO
FLIP BOTH THE HOUSE OF
REPRESENTATIVES AND THE SENATE,
DONALD TRUMP IS PREPARING TO
RIDE THAT WAVE RIGHT INTO A
2024 ANNOUNCEMENT.
SOURCES TELL CNN THAT TOP AIDES
TO THE FORMER PRESIDENT ARE
GEARING UP FOR A POSSIBLE
CAMPAIGN LAUNCH AROUND THE
THIRD WEEK OF NOVEMBER,
SOMETHING TRUMP HIMSELF HINTED
ON THE CAMPAIGN TRAIL AGAIN
LAST NIGHT.
>> NOW IN ORDER TO MAKE OUR
COUNTRY SUCCESSFUL AND SAFE AND
GLORIOUS, I WILL VERY, VERY,
VERY PROBABLY DO IT AGAIN.
OKAY?
>> THE SAME SOURCES, HOWEVER,
SAY TRUMP'S ANNOUNCEMENT COULD
BE DELAYED IF REPUBLICANS DO
NOT DO AS WELL AS HE HOPES.
AND PERHAPS AN ANNOUNCEMENT
COULD COME EARLIER IF THERE'S A
REPUBLICAN TSUNAMI NEXT WEEK.
WHO KNOWS.
IT IS DONALD TRUMP.
THERE ARE SOME MAJOR HEADLINES
TODAY THAT COULD HAVE AN IMPACT
ON WHAT HAPPENS TUESDAY.
STARTING WITH A STRONGER THAN
EXPECTED JOBS REPORT RELEASED
TODAY.
261,000 AMERICANS HIRED IN
OCTOBER IN A NORMAL CAMPAIGN
YEAR --
THAT WOULD BE WELCOME NEWS FOR
THE WHITE HOUSE AND DEMOCRATS
RUNNING ACROSS THE COUNTRY.
BUT THIS IS NOT A NORMAL YEAR
AND THE ECONOMIC PICTURE IS
MUCH MORE COMPLICATED AND, IN
THE VIEW OF MOST AMERICANS,
PRETTY DARN DISMAL.
PRESIDENT BIDEN'S LABOR
SECRETARY SPOKE OF THE DILEMMA
FACING DEMOCRATS.
>> AT THE END OF THE DAY, NO
MATTER HOW MANY JOBS THAT I CAN
GET IN FRONT OF THIS CAMERA AND
TELL YOU THAT WE'VE ADDED AND
HOW GREAT THEY ARE, PEOPLE ARE
STILL FEELING THE STRUGGLE AT
THE KITCHEN TABLE.
>> THE BIGGEST ECONOMIC
CHALLENGE AT THE MOMENT SEEMS
TO BE INFLATION.
AND YES, WE ALSO SAW TODAY THAT
AMERICANS WAGES ARE RISING.
BUT THEY ARE NOT KEEPING UP
WITH THE COST OF NEARLY
EVERYTHING ELSE THAT IS
SOARING.
THAT, WE HEARD THIS WEEK,
REMAINS THE BIGGEST CONCERN OF
THE CHAIRMAN OF THE FEDERAL
RESERVE.
>> WITHOUT PRICED ABILITY THE
ECONOMY DOES NOT WORK FOR
ANYONE.
>> THE TRICK IS, THE FEDS
RESPONSE TO EASE INFLATION,
WHICH TO RAISE INTEREST RATES
AGAIN, ANOTHER THREE QUARTERS
OF A POINT, WE CHEATED ON
WEDNESDAY.
AND WHILE WE ALL WANT PRICES TO
GO DOWN, THAT MOVE --
MORE EXPENSIVE.
AND IT ALSO MAKES IT HARDER FOR
DEMOCRATS TO WIN AT THE BALLOT
BOX IN A NUMBER OF KEY RACES.
TAKE A TRIP WITH ME ACROSS THE
COUNTRY AS WE VISIT SOME OF
THOSE RACES.
LET'S START IN MY HOME
COMMONWEALTH OF PENNSYLVANIA,
WHERE OPRAH IS WEIGHING IN,
ENDORSING DEMOCRAT JOHN
FETTERMAN OVER THE MAN SHE
TURNED INTO A HOUSEHOLD NAME.
URNED INTO A>> IF I LIVED IN PEI
WOULD HAVE ALREADY CAST MY VOTE
FOR JOHN FETTERMAN, FOR MANY
REASONS.
>> FETTERMAN'S OPPONENT,
REPUBLICAN CANDIDATE MEHMET OZ,
SKYROCKETED TO FAME, OF COURSE,
BECAUSE OF HIS RECURRING
SEGMENTS ON THE OPRAH WINFREY
SHOW.
AND THAT LED HIM TO HIS OWN
SYNDICATED SHOW, WHICH WAS
COPRODUCED BY OPRAH.
>> SOMETIMES, THESE THINGS COME
ALIVE.
A LITTLE SLEEPY HERE.
NOW THESE CAN GROW --
CAN YOU HOLD THAT, PLEASE?
>> NO!
--
A LITTLE BIT THERE.
>> ON TO THE DAIRY STATES NOW,
ANOTHER CANDIDATE OBRADOR'S FOR
THE SENATE, AND THAT OF COURSE
IS WISCONSIN'S CANDIDATE FOR
LIEUTENANT GOVERNOR, MANDELA
BARNES --
REPUBLICAN SENATOR RON JOHNSON
AFTER JOHNSON WOULD NOT
EXPLICITLY, WITHOUT
EQUIVOCATION, COMMIT TO
ACCEPTING THE ELECTION RESULTS
NEXT WEEK.
>> A PERSON WHO WOULD GO SO FAR
AS SAYING, WELL, I DIDN'T GET
WHAT I WANTED, SO, IT CAN'T BE
RIGHT --
IT'S VERY ARROGANT.
IT'S THE HEIGHT OF ARROGANCE.
THAT'S WHAT HE HAS ALWAYS BEEN
AND WILL CONTINUE TO BE.
>> AND ACROSS THE COUNTRY IN
ARIZONA, MORE THAN 1.2 MILLION
EARLY BALLOTS HAVE ALREADY BEEN
CAST.
NOWHERE --
NOWHERE IN THE UNITED STATES
HAS THE STRUGGLE BETWEEN
ELECTION LIARS AND THOSE WHO
RESIDE HERE ON PLANET EARTH --
PLAYED OUT IN MORE VIVID DETAIL
THAN IN ARIZONA, WHERE THREE OF
THE KEY REPUBLICAN CANDIDATES
--
FOR GOVERNOR, FOR SENATE, AND
FOR SECRETARY OF STATE OF
ARIZONA --
ALL TRAFFIC IN DONALD TRUMP'S
LIES ABOUT THE 2020 ELECTION
AND IT VENTED CONSPIRATORIAL
CLAIMS OF WIDESPREAD FRAUD THAT
NEVER HAPPENED.
AND ELECTION LIARS IN ARIZONA
--
THEY ARE NOT JUST ON THE
BALLOT.
THEY ARE ALSO AT THE BALLOT
BOXES.
THIS WEEK, A FEDERAL JUDGE IN
THE GRAND CANYON STATE BLOCKED
A WHITE RING GROUP FROM POOR
TRIALING --
CLEAN ELECTIONS USA ACCUSED
THEM --
THESE VOTERS --
OF VOTER FRAUD, WHILE OPENLY
CARRYING GUNS AND WEARING BODY
ARMOR AND MASKS AND RECORDING
THE VOTERS.
AND RECORDING >> YEAH, I COVERE
BECAUSE YOU ARE TAKING PICTURES
AND ALL THAT STUFF.
THAT'S WHAT WE COME TO IN
AMERICA.
THESE GUYS CALL THEMSELVES
PATRIOTS?
REALLY?
THE GUY STANDING OVER THERE,
HE'S GOT HIS FACE COVERED AND
HE IS ARMED.
WHAT DOES THAT TELL YOU?
THEY DON'T WANT YOU TO VOTE.
>> THE JUSTICE DEPARTMENT SAYS
THE ALLEGATIONS, QUOTE, RAISE
SERIOUS CONCERNS A VOTER
INTIMIDATION, UNQUOTE, AND
LIKELY VIOLATE THE FEDERAL
VOTING RIGHTS ACT.
CENTRAL, OF COURSE, TO THIS IS
THE LIE FILLED PROPAGANDA FILM
2000 MULES WE HAVE TOLD YOU
ABOUT.
IT'S A FILM PROPAGANDA,
CLAIMING WITH ZERO EVIDENCE
THAT DROP BOX IS WHERE THE
SCENES OF MASS VOTER FRAUD OF
2020 --
SPOILER ALERT, THEY WEREN'T.
BUT THE ORGANIZER OF THE GROUP
BEHIND THIS CAMPAIGN WENT ON
STEVE BANNON SHOW AND EXPLAIN
TO MILLIONS OF LISTENERS HOW
THAT PROPAGANDA FILM FULL OF
LIES AND NONSENSE INSPIRED THIS
BALLOT WATCHING MOVEMENT.
LISTENERS HOW >> REALLY, WHAT IS
THE IDEA OF 2000 MEALS --
TRUTH SOCIAL ONE DAY AND SAID,
HEY, WE ARE SUPPOSED TO BE
THERE --
THEY ARE STEALING IT.
LET'S GET OUT THERE AND SHIFT
THOSE, MAYBE, TWO OR THREE
HOURS, --
AHEAD OF TIME.
AND JUST STAND OUT THERE.
KEEP THOSE MEALS FROM WANTING
TO COME TO THE BOX.
IT'S A SIMPLE POT AND IT JUST
TOOK OFF.
>> A SIMPLE THOUGHT IS
ACCURATE.
SO, --
JUDGES ORDER MAKES IT ILLEGAL
TO STOP ARIZONA BALLOT BOXES
AND VOTERS.
BUT THE MISINFORMATION DRIVING
ALL OF THIS, THAT CONTINUES TO
STOP ALL CORNERS OF AMERICAN
DEMOCRACY.
HERE IS THE REPUBLICAN OUTGOING
SPEAKER OF THE ARIZONA HOUSE,
RUSTY BOWERS, A CONSERVATIVE
REPUBLICAN, TALKING ABOUT HIS
FEARS ABOUT THE ANTI-DEMOCRACY
CANDIDATES AND EFFORTS IN HIS
STATE.
>> I CALL IT THE POSSIBILITY OF
GOING BACK INTO THE DARK AGES
IN TERMS OF --
WHICH WOULD BE A SAD TIME.
I SAID, WELCOME TO FASCISM.
>> THESE LIES, THEY'RE THE
CENTERPIECE OF MANY MAGA
CANDIDATES RUNNING IN
BATTLEGROUND STATES SUCH AS
ARIZONA.
AND A REAL CONCERN FOR ANY
AMERICAN WHO WANTS ALL LEGAL
VOTES COUNTED.
WE SAW MORE OF THE IMPACT OF
MISINFORMATION ONE WEEK AGO
TODAY AFTER A DERANGED MAN SET
OUT TO HARM HOUSE SPEAKER NANCY
PELOSI, BREAKING INTO HER HOUSE
AND VIOLENTLY BEATING HER
HUSBAND WITH A HAMMER,
PRESIDENT BIDEN ADDRESSED THIS
GENERAL THREATEN OF PRIMETIME
SPEECH THIS WEEK AND, ONCE
AGAIN, HE WARNED THE AMERICAN
PEOPLE NOT TO TAKE DEMOCRACY
FOR GRANTED.
>> THIS INTIMIDATION, THIS
VIOLENCE AGAINST DEMOCRATS,
REPUBLICANS AND NON PARTISAN
OFFICIALS, JUST DOING THEIR
JOBS, WITH THE CONSEQUENCES OF
LIES TOLD FOR POWER AND PROFIT
--
WE HAVE TO CONFRONT THOSE LIES
WITH THE TRUTH.
THE VERY FUTURE OF OUR NATION
DEPENDS ON IT.
>> BUT CAN PEOPLE HEAR THIS
WARNING AMIDST THE CACOPHONOUS
OF ECONOMIC HARD TIMES?
BECAUSE WE KNOW THAT MIDTERM
VOTERS TOP CONCERN, ACCORDING
TO POLLS, IS NOT THE FUTURE OF
DEMOCRACY.
IT IS THE CURRENT STATE OF THE
ECONOMY, WHICH IS
UNDERSTANDABLE, GIVEN THE VERY
REAL FINANCIAL STRUGGLES FOLKS
ARE FACING.
THAT'S AS OPPOSED TO
THEORETICAL LIMITATIONS OF
FREEDOM TO VOTE IN THE FUTURE.
TODAY, I ASKED A DEMOCRATIC
POLLSTER HOW DEMOCRATS HE,
THINKS, WILL FARE IN THE
MIDTERM ELECTIONS, WHAT HE IS
SEEING OUT THERE.
HE RESPONDED SIMPLY WITH THIS
SCREEN GRAB THE, IMAGE OF A
CATEGORY FOUR HURRICANE MAKING
LANDFALL.
IT'S NOT A G